[Musique]
pierpoljak surnommé par ses amis pire on
le fout au début dès qu il connaît la
maison puis s'envole à bord d'un voilier
et débarque un jour en jamaïque
[Musique]
on ne compte que sur nous mêmes quoi ce
soir les pirates certains pirates aussi
tu vois mais là dans le studio avec eux
c'est de la piraterie mais organiser
quoi tu vois c'est la rigueur il ya des
règles en compagnie importe quoi le
saint des saints le studio de bob marley
à kingston pierpoljak est venu
enregistrer les titres de son troisième
album à la baguette
leeroy horsemouth wallace le plus grands
batteurs du pays à la console l'iphone
un producteur qui a collaboré entre
autres avec bob marley jimmy cliff
chaude je ne pense pas qu'il se sente ou
lilas doivent se sentir comme un artiste
français chantant du reggae doit sentir
comme un chanteur reggae moi mais c'est
ce que je m'évertue renseigner et je
crois qu'il va y arriver il adapte
[Musique]
comme fondu dans le décor
le baroudeur a traîné son port d'attache
du reggae émission affaires ca c'est en
tant que chanteur de reggae c'est à
respecter cette musique quoi m c'est à
dire les mails à connaître quoi savoir
d'où elle vient comment elle est née
comment elle a grandi le reggae musique
c'est une musique de gens qui souffrent
encore tu vois c'est une musique de de
gens malheureux en fin de compte le
gamin du colombes a quitté la cité
oublier son passé tourmenté
à 35 ans le pirate a trouvé son île la
jamaïque pierpoljak la grande évasion un
mauvais garçon qui retrouvait la
rédemption grâce à la chanson